good to see you as always let's dive
straight into Kramer tours that we would
just uh just learning more about and
clearly devastating effects on the
ground there what is the Strategic
significance of of that particular
attack yes slovenians got two key places
now in this battle that's going to
develop in the Southeast
um the ukrainians look as if they've
been pushed out of ism and that was
their base for quite a long time and
that's pretty that's a an important loss
and it looks as if the Russians are now
trying to push down between slaviant and
they've already bombed the railway line
between the two to cut off
Communications and Military
communication but it also makes it more
difficult for civilians of course to
move around and it looks as if the
Russians are trying now to complete this
circle between isium slovenians
clamatosk and luhansk to try to create a
circle and trap large parts of the
Ukrainian Army on the wrong side of it
to encircle them it's quite a task
they've got and they've only just begun
to do it and and most of the
reinforcements haven't yet arrived one
suspects that they're under enormous
pressure from the Kremlin to do
something dramatic in the next couple of
weeks before President Putin's Victory
Day Parade on the 9th of May but we'll
see how that works out but chromatos can
slow the answer at the moment is the
centerpiece of this battle that is
forming for the southeast of the country
and we'll get a glimpse of that
Southeast region and its importance when
we zoom out now to uh all of Ukraine you
mentioned uh the need to get
reinforcements and and the troops in
particular pulling back from from Kiev
how long does that does that take for
the Russians and and do they need the
troops from Kiev to be successful in the
East they certainly do they but the
point is they're forces in the in the
North lost and they lost quite heavily
it looks as if about half of the
Battalion tactical groups which are
fighting units about half of them were
either destroyed or badly damaged and so
they're having to reform a number of new
Battalion tactical groups re-equip them
and essentially what they're doing by
rushing in this way they're sending an
army that's already been beaten I mean
round the outside as it were through the
Russian corridors because that's where
their railway lines run and they've got
to take the heavy equipment effectively
by rail back into a new battle that's
forming in the Southeast meanwhile the
ukrainians they've got an easier job
getting from Kiev to their area of the
Battle Zone that's internal but any
material that they get from the west and
they've said look we need weapons
weapons weapons that's what the foreign
minister said at NATO yesterday and they
need them quick but the fact is they did
have a supply line that was about 600
kilometers long from the Polish border
towards Kiev they've now got to take
that line and then bring them down into
the southeast so they've now got a line
of about 1200 kilometers much further to
go to get some supplies to them so both
sides have got their relative logistical
challenges and basically what we're
seeing is a race to the southeast to
join the battle which looks as if it
will determine this next phase of the
war how crucial then is this next week
maybe before the race is over before
both sides can kind of get to their
maximum strength in that region is this
next week absolutely critical yeah it's
always said when you put arrows that I
was on a map like this I mean amateurs
talk strategy professionals talk
Logistics and this next week coming is a
is a week for professionals to talk
Logistics well you're the professional
here Michael I'm the amateur but it's
always great to hear from you thank you
so much Michael Clark